I'm gonna see if you know the song if
you know the song you get your gangsta
credit this is not even like a hundred
percent gangster song it was a remix of
one of the greatest hip-hop artists of
all time
Tupac Shakur every corner every city
there's a place where life's a little
easy little Hennessy lay back and cool
every hour good it's so good we polled
jacker know nothing what did you listen
to growing up then a lot of a lot of
rock music Oh see that's the [ __ ] that I
don't know about yeah I feel like I
[ __ ] up because you know what I when I
talked to Tim or Gio or Bart I feel like
their their knowledge and library of
music is a lot bigger than mine oh hell
yeah
because for me it's just uh it's like
hip-hop and R&B but outside of that I
didn't listen to him to a lot of genres
so every time like people they reference
like some I don't know well name like a
rock band that used to listen to yellow
card see I know I should know a couple
it so if you see a yellow card song
because it was so popular on the radio
yeah I can remember it so sing one right
now if I could find you now things would
get better if we leave this town we run
forever
what's the chorus I heard the chorus oh
is it but I heard that song before right
so that's during the time where there
was there was a lot of like uh like emo
yeah that's that alternative rock is
that what that's pop it was yellow card
was another band oh my gosh there's
all-time low there was all-american
rejects see an all-american I know it
all I guarantee you all know one of
those songs that you'll sing from them
oh my gosh what's that one that goes all
the small things is it who's that oh
that's blink-182 is it [ __ ] I don't know
[ __ ] man
small things tooth cares tooth rings
always I know you'll be at my show
watching waiting basic [ __ ] lyrics
I've ever heard of my life but that's it
so I will not go turn the lights off
carry me home oh my god dude see you and
I grew up in like two different worlds
but I definitely know that music because
it was so popular it was on the radio so
even if I didn't like [ __ ] with the
genre just because it was constantly
being blasted this was by the way prior
to [ __ ] Spotify and everything else
so it just permeated into our lives
because you were just hear it on the
radio yeah all the [ __ ] time I feel
like Smash Mouth would be your jam okay
seeing a smash smash mouth song right
now cuz that right now that sounds like
a dope oh my god somebody once told me
the world is gonna roll me okay like I'm
not the sharpest tool in the shed
I forgot I totally forgot the lyrics but
it's like yeah why does that resonate
with me because yeah and then there's
something like that l wish like L on the
shape of your I don't know something
something on the shape of your forehead
I tell you forgot what about this how
many brothers fell victim to this breach
rusted piece young n-word
there's that no no I don't know that one
I mean I think the other one I probably
would know would be like baby got back
LD one or what is house is not one song
go where it's like move [ __ ] get out
the bolita Kristen really like popular
hits - yeah you don't know anything like
Kanye West or anything I know some Kanye
West but I don't know a lot though like
I never do all like dwelled into like
the hip hop like oh but crab was not
even like his college dropout album no
dude that was a good album yeah yeah you
don't know any song from the college
dropper not by heart but I'm sure I
heard it then that Buffalo is in the
pocket like wallets I got that bounce
like hydraulics I can call it I got this
world
alcoholics ha do I freaking love that
album dude kanye west's college dropout
arguably is one of the best hip-hop
albums of all time I [ __ ] said it
what do you think about um his what was
it 808 heartbreak
yo 808 and heartbreaks was so weird
because for me I didn't really [ __ ] with
it that hard but a lot of people that I
know that liked it and the reason why is
because Kanye West is somebody who
constantly just reinvented himself so
every album that came out was a
representation of what was going on in
his life at the time
so 808 and heartbreaks I I'm thinking
from what I've read I can't remember now
but he was going through some [ __ ] some
heartbreak yeah
and so that was like his his his ode to
his emotions at that time I mean his
production quality is always wild as
[ __ ] I mean there was a few tracks on
ate away in heartbreaks I can't remember
them right now but if you if after
college dropout graduation it kind of
went a little off for me and then
obviously you liked his tracks before
that time his mixtapes were really dope
but when it starts to get into a twigs I
was that was that one track saying no no
no no no I love and you know that yeah
that one yeah you know I didn't vibe
with it at the time because it wasn't
what I was going through but a lot of
the stuff that he did before just
because he was such like he was so
crafty with his words yeah and then on
top of that like his production quality
was amazing like I didn't get to go to
his I really wanted to go to his
graduation concerts because during when
that album came out I heard his [ __ ]
concerts were wild I'm talking about
here like a full choir and everything I
never got to experience that [ __ ] and by
the time I had money to go to his
concerts it's by the time I [ __ ]
started hating him so even on some weird
[ __ ] I see yeah I don't think I really
got into hip-hop very much when I was
younger just because whatever was
playing on the radio it just really
turned me off just based on the lyrics
itself cuz a lot of it was like a lot
about drugs and sex and just like
literally anything that I just didn't
really resonate with and so to me it
just it just wasn't relatable and so I
was like I'm not living that life and it
doesn't make me feel hard like like you
know like I'm okay yeah it to me I'm
just like wow that's just gross that's
very honest with you know a lot of
people will listen that music and they
feel like they want to live that
lifestyle which is so so weird to me you
know so you listen to like I'm just a
teenage dirtbag baby baby yeah that kind
of woes that one band called Papa Roach
[Applause]
music was so emotional yeah you know a
lot of hip-hop is actually going towards
that route they call it like like like
email rap right which is which is cool
like I think I couldn't definitely
relate to it now well yeah I mean that
stuff it's very much so I mean if you're
younger to you may not realize but a lot
of that alternative rock [ __ ] is the emo
rap that you're listening to right now
it's just done with a different beat now
and obviously it's done through hip-hop
but the subject matter and how is
connecting with the youth is basically
like teenage angst like you feel like
you're not being understood you feel
like things aren't really going your way
relationship problems which you know
hip-hop back in the day I mean they
would have loved songs and stuff like I
remember when LL Cool J did that that
song with boys to men like they had
those type of like mixing [ __ ] but yeah
it was more like about shooting and
killing people yeah I just couldn't
relate nor did I want to do anything
like that so yeah it to me I just didn't
really want to listen to it did you did
you so aside from like rock what else
did you listen to I guess some pop but I
honestly don't remember I feel like the
type of rock music I listen to I think a
lot of rock people don't see it as rock
because it's like more like pop punk or
like alternative rock oh is it like beef
within like the rock commune
if you wasn't a punk rock and you listen
to alternative rock it's like the [ __ ]
is that I mean they cross over a lot
together but I think like those that you
know compared to like just classical
rock or just rock as in like I don't
know [ __ ] what oh my god
what do you call them uh how [ __ ]
dare you do I know I was thinking about
Aerosmith but then that's not quite it I
was thinking um oh my god Oh Creed okay
no oh my god who sing uh Bohemian
Rhapsody the are you talking about huh I
was about to say Prince not Prince David
so [ __ ] mustache [ __ ] AIDS yeah
but I forgot the band name that sing it
I'm sorry Mike I should know this too
yeah and my mind is going [ __ ] blank
for somebody who does music I don't know
[ __ ] about music yeah but I mean like
for something of that bad I'm sorry guys
out there that I kept for the like oh my
god how am I getting his [ __ ] name
yeah oh um something mercury Freddie
Mercury Freddy Mercury yeah but then he
was of what band though Freddie Mercury
of what band regardless like I mean I
feel like those are the people that feel
like that's what rock is and that's like
what good rock is yeah and then for me
it's just like child's play
dude did you like music growing up or
was it wasn't just something that you
would it would just be on here and there
but you never really liked a hundred
percent got into it uh I think from you
was pretty much as on here and there and
then when I did get into it it was just
only a specific sound
mhm yeah do music for me was just for me
to get women to talk to me dude that's
no that's the only thing I ever gave a
[ __ ] about dude is that went right when
I picked up that guitar I'm like dude
I'm trying to get some [ __ ] it was
like the thing though are you telling me
that you didn't have one of those little
Asian [ __ ] with a guitar on campus
although I know those [ __ ] dude I
wasn't one of them
I brought my guitar specifically because
I had choir and then we would like
practice music together but other than
that I wouldn't bring it there cuz I
feel weird I thought you're gonna do a
little bit of like dashboard confessions
oh my god save me a dashboard
confessionals confessional song right
now
I don't [ __ ] I don't I don't remember
I think it was I do remember I think
they did one for spider-man it was a
long-ass time ago see these these bands
like if you say it I'll remember it yeah
but when I was in high school Switchfoot
Switchfoot yeah I know that band but I
don't know anything music really yeah
you might have heard it if you sing it
like I said if you sing it I'll probably
know it there's one that says like it
goes like I don't know any lyrics but
dude there was it was so funny because
when I was in high school there was a
dude that was really popping off off of
it wasn't I don't want to say it was
SoundCloud it could have been SoundCloud
or some iteration of what it was before
that but he was huge before YouTube was
popping and he was really put in like
R&B and acoustic music on on this on the
spot and it was two people at a time it
was this guy it was two Filipino cats
him what by passion yes we were passion
and Oh Gabe bundok and so everybody used
to take their music go to campus
practice it at home make sure that the
[ __ ] was on point
go find themselves a nice big booty
[ __ ] Filipino girl and sing that song
did and that [ __ ] right there is how I
lost my virginity Jeremy passion thank
you so much Jeremy passion helped me
lose my virginity because that song was
powerful as hell if you sang his song
lemonade yeah dude all the girls were
like oh my god who's dead so you're
sniff it sing it sniffing I want to hear
it oh [ __ ] I'm I should know this
because dude I to go when I heard that
song first of all I [ __ ] with the song
cuz I loved it yeah and then on top of
that I was like this right here cuz he's
gonna get a woman to touch my penis and
that [ __ ] [ __ ] work dude he doesn't
know he's probably one of the biggest
reasons why at that
time a lot of dweeby asian guys lost
their virginity because every good
opportunities for you guys open the
gateway to the first vagina I've ever
had and I have not turned back since
Jeremy passion you don't know man you've
been poppin cherry since since the year
2000 dude thank you so much man
you know he actually tweeted me a long
time ago saying I don't want to say he
said he was a fan of my but he knew who
I was but he doesn't know that I've been
knowing before he knew who I was who he
was dude he don't even know that dude
you didn't bring him on I would love to
but I think he lives out in the Bay Area
there was a lot of cats that were on
this space before YouTube popped off
that kind of really put it on for some
Asian dudes because he was one of those
dudes that he has kind of like a music I
say a Musiq Soulchild vibe so I could I
mean I could be wrong I haven't really
talked to him but just listening to his
music and his and the chord progressions
that he uses
he clearly listens to a lot of music
soul child and I root and I love music
soulchild he was like one of my like RMB
like gods that I used to follow back in
the day and I gotta tell you man
lemonade do you remember that song I
don't that's why I'm asking you to sing
it [ __ ]
she's my sunshine in the rain I can
remember something like that but it was
like it was a it was such a like
touching love song yeah it wasn't mine
when you looked into the windows of a
woman's soul they thought oh my god this
[ __ ] for me I mean I think the first
time I heard about passion was when is a
first started highest a stands for what
something secret agents like in turn is
an international secret agents no but
that was started by a Wong foo yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so they had that and on
the set list
it was Wong foo and there was kina
grannis and then there was passion and I
think AJ raffia
yo kina grannis one time I was doing
this show out in San Francisco it was
for this Chinese New Year thing and
Verizon actually throws some kind of
like major event in Chinatown in San
Francisco I think they're one of the
major sponsors and the kina grannis was
performing and I was up there with my
homegirl Nicky son mm-hmm and kina
grannis she touched my forearm and I
freaked the [ __ ] out kina grannis you
don't even know I did not wash that
forearm for three weeks you know I
actually bumped into some friends at ISA
and I was like oh and like date there
were the type of friends I didn't
actually expect him to be at that event
yeah and I asked him like what they were
doing there and they're like oh we're
here for kina grannis and I was like -
that's it right and then like as soon as
kina grannis finished her set they're
like all right we're bouncing see you
later
of course kina grannis man she was I
mean not was she she's first of all a
talented musician very tell she was so
pretty yeah she is very pretty she's one
of the only girls that I know that went
after she chopped off her hair I was
like I actually liked you even more yeah
she's real cute with her hair like sure
she could do whatever she wants - I love
you kina but I'm taken like in fact that
matters I like how I say that as if it
ever [ __ ] mattered on earth like she
even knows who I am I guarantee you it's
Mary right yeah she's mean she's happy
dude yeah could be happier I'm I'm
kidding I have I have Mary I love her so
much
oh good yeah but music on that during
that time was so interesting because um
prior to prior to like Spotify and all
this other stuff in like YouTube was
like that platform that everybody used
to go out there and really like show
what they had and I think like when I
was growing up like having an Asian guy
singing like R&B music was not a thing
like people did not expect that so you
know just to go back to Jeremy passion
when he was he was doing it I just had
to jump on that [ __ ] wave dude and I
was trying to be a comic too but I was
like yo man making people laugh does not
get me vagina whatsoever
it would always be a situation where
like if let's say we're at I was at a
bar or something this is like in my 20s
like oh you should meet my friend David
man he makes he's really really funny
it's like cool and it goes like oh
you're really funny cool but then they
would leave with some other guy head I'm
okay you know what I need to start doing
music that's what I'm you do because
music is amazing
hell yeah I remember um watching your
skits cuz I was definitely I was
introduced to you with the UCLA girl
yeah video the rat that you had about
her and then I think slowly on your
channel you started to promote that you
had your music channel yeah I'm actually
started with the music channel first
before my comedy I didn't know but yeah
and so like um because you like
cross-reference those channels together
yeah um I clicked on one of your videos
and you started seeing I was like oh my
god dude this fool can sing I wanted to
be a musician first so prior prior to by
David so comedy channel I actually had a
music channel before that that I deleted
so my type of personality and maybe I
didn't share this story before but I
deleted it and you know at the time I
can't remember the exact subscribers
subscriber count that I had on it but it
was pretty high for the time whatever I
might have said like a random number
before just to give something you know
give something for people to buy it on
yeah but let's say it was like I don't
know like a hundred thousand followers
during that time it was a lot this is
during my music channel days I deleted
all those videos so in the same fashion
that I had what like genius brain when I
when I when I rebranded my channel from
Davis Davis Okami to genius brain I did
the same thing for my music - going into
comedy and the reason why I did that was
because I when I was trying to be a
comic there was it there was a big issue
that I had write and it's a lot of
issues that I think young people have
when I was young and the biggest problem
that that is is having too many options
and I wanted to do everything and
anything and it's still a problem that I
had till this day it's like when you
want to do everything and anything the
problem with that is that you'll never
be able to master a single craft really
well if you master craft it's gonna be a
constant thing that's going on but you
won't be able to get to a certain level
if you keep splitting up your time with
six or seven different things so when I
started doing music I started doing
music and comedy around the same time
but I was way more into music than it
was comedy and so I had to make a choice
I was like okay so what are you going to
be are you going to be a comic are you
going to be a musician and
during this time I was putting more time
in the music but I fell in love with
comedy so I had to make a choice so I
could keep this acoustic soul or
whatever but I felt that because I had
this it was it was gonna hold me back so
I did a very tough thing at the time I
deleted that channel I completely
deleted it not like not just hide it
private it no I don't I don't even know
if YouTube had that option at that time
or maybe I was just dumb and I didn't
know he's deleted the whole [ __ ]
channel but I actually deleted my music
channel that had maybe like a hundred
thousand followers and whatever that
number was it was a big big
accomplishment and I was booking shows
through that like San Francisco and I
was doing that show collaboration before
I even became a bigger youtuber because
I was so focused on music and so when I
left that I deleted it I said you know
what there's no turning back delete that
channel we want to start a comedy one
yeah and I started my comedy when David
saw comedy after I deleted that channel
so then how did you fall in love with
comedy because like you're so into music
yeah but I was always doing comedy like
I started you know I had fake IDs I
would hit up these comedy clubs and
because I was I was this sick I was like
six foot one when I was three years old
so you know I mean and I still don't
have facial hair but I I'm I'm more
curious about how your fake ID look like
it just it looked like a regular
California license ID I know what was it
with your picture on there yeah I see
like I've looked I wish it was hoping
that it was a picture that looked
completely different from here no it was
my face and you know like tooth like
some of these clubs don't give a [ __ ]
dude you know so um I would get into
these comedy clubs and then um long
story short I just started falling in
love with comedy more and to be honest
with you was it was mainly because I
think I was just a better comedian than
I was a musician like I never really
loved music as much as I love making
people laugh and the reason why was
because like even right now and it goes
back to me understanding um just like
music history I know nothing about it
like you know we were struggling to say
say who Freddie Mercury was yeah you
know somebody who's like highly iconic
in in music in general and I don't know
these people I don't know all this
different music even if you asked like
pop artist right you asked him about
certain musicians that made big waves
even if it's outside of their genre
they'll know what what we're what
they're talking about whoever whatever
or whatever that person is talking about
if they're having a conversation with
somebody about music and that's because
it's their job I didn't have that same
passion for music I I did not and so for
me I had to understand okay are you
going to waste your time on something
that's just a hobby just because you're
using it just because it gives you
attention or are you gonna put your time
into something that makes you really
happy right right and comedy made me
happy comedy was away from me since I
was a little kid I was a goofball yeah
right I didn't know the craft about it I
didn't go to like UCB or anything else
like that I just had real world world
experience I just went up on stage and I
saw what happened so comedy was
something that just always rewarded me
with something that was more than just
like recognition like the the ability to
make somebody laugh about something
you're not supposed to laugh about was a
task that I really enjoyed and it
started off with me right so when like I
think we mentioned this before and on
the podcast that we did I was a fat kid
still a bigger guy now but as a fat kid
a lot of kids would make fun of you
whether it was because of my glass is
the way I looked the way I behaved or
what it didn't really matter but with
comedy you're allowed to take those
negative attributes and flip it and make
it into something funny so I would do
that by making fun of myself first
before somebody else could yeah and for
me laughter and comedy was so healing
yeah which made me want to pursue it and
I think like that's why I went into the
stand-up Brown yeah so stand-up was like
the big thing for me because being able
to grab a mic go up on stage make people
laugh and people said like you do like
you just you know yeah crack me the [ __ ]
up and changed my perspective how was
how was your first your very first
performance like my very first
performance was actually this church
like right around the corner from my
place I was right across this park that
we use go but there was a church that
opened up in like this warehouse area
and they did an open mic comedy night
and I just remember I just walked in
there and I just did a terrible terrible
set it was so [ __ ] bad like bad
because no one laughed
nobody left that was not funny I was not
funny I see you know just because
because people
understand like just because you're our
funny person doesn't mean you could do
stand-up comedy
I have a friend back in Sacramento that
wanted to do stand-up too and he did
stand-up and mind you if we're in a
conversation let's say like me and you
like let's say you're obviously I'm me
and you're him right he that fool could
make me laugh and go into tears yeah but
if you put him on stage with the mic cuz
he thought that the the conversations
that we were having that he could turn
into stand-up but he couldn't because it
takes skill it takes storytelling it
takes nuance takes practice is it's it's
it's a really difficult craft yeah I'm
not saying I'm an amazing stand-up comic
but you know I've I can do it decently
yeah you know I I obviously haven't
practiced it in years but this guy he
didn't really understand how difficult
stand-up was and so he went up on stage
and he bought and this is him like later
on this is I after like six years I've
been doing stand-up he started doing
stand-up - and he would just go up on
stage and [ __ ] crickets because he
would try to tell these stories on stage
to a group of strangers but the reason
why they were funny to us is because the
people that he would talk about in those
stories we knew who they were so there
was already a background to it so he
would never setup his jokes and we would
try to get him to understand that and he
just kept bombing over all oh that
sounds like a name there it is it's
nerve-racking it's hard stand up is a
very difficult craft that's why when I
watch people like Bobby Lee he's been
doing it for years the guy's a master
his craft yeah do you know um obviously
I mean I'm still still a fan of you
David but like when I was a super fan
like way back because I didn't know much
about you I tried so hard to try to find
videos of you doing your stand-up and
like I was just trying to figure out
there's a few now I know there is a few
like I managed to find a few and I was
one of those people that was so down and
ready to [ __ ] buy a ticket and watch
you do stand-up yeah I am when I was
doing stand-up pretty actively so it was
only when I first started like the first
two years and so I would go like the
Icehouse Pasadena and I would like do
material but then I slowly started to
find out that a lot of these a lot of
these college shows were different than
doing a stand-up at a at an actual
comedy club so comedy clubs they were a
lot more open
you could say what I'm talking about you
go to comedy clubs depending on which
one you go to and who goes up it will
say some wild [ __ ] and nobody really
gets that offended you know aside from
saying very like racially offensive
things depending on who that person is
right so let's say if a white dudes up
their knees thrashing on black people as
a joke probably not gonna go over really
well right right or if a dude is
thrashing on women without any nuance
and not without any background to it
then obviously it's gonna go bad but
other than that is pretty open it was a
it was like a safe space you get to go
up there go to a comedy club test your
material out if it fails go back to the
drawing board either you rewrite that
joke you say if you still believe in the
joke you either rewrite it or you trash
it and move on yeah yeah College shows
were a little different it was more it
wasn't a lot of the stuff that would
kill in the comedy club that I would use
mm-hmm I would try to do at a college
shows if people get either offender or
they feel weird about it oh this is a
very different space so for me before
though I would walk up on stage I would
like people to the blinds and the
curtains and I would take a look at
everybody out there yeah like I would
look I'm like what's the age group yeah
how many women are in there how many
dudes and I would kind of base it off of
that type of stuff just because like I
felt like the college crowd was a little
more sensitive they wouldn't listen to
the comedy they would just listen for
trigger words and get mad mm-hmm
and I hated that [ __ ] because it's like
dude you got to listen to the content
first like don't just get angry just to
be angry at this point right so like I
mean I plan to do stand-up again
starting actually next year I would love
to go and see you I want to support you
let me buy the ticket yeah so we're
gonna like I'm definitely gonna do
stand-up next year for sure my people
don't know like in this phone and in my
computer I have literally like hundreds
of pages of stand-up I constantly write
all the time it's just something I did
I've done since I was 16 yeah yeah
whenever I find something funny I write
it down oh my gosh so then like prior to
you actually performing up on stage how
like I guess how long do you practice
like do you do you do your whole set it
depends for me because I had such short
sets when I first started out and I was
an absolute nobody I rarely ever got
like past 15 minutes to do a set yeah I
didn't prep much I have a lot of hitters
and I would do a lot of crowd work
the longest show that I did was out in
Minnesota I did an hour set whoa yeah I
did an hour set that was super barge
over there so they were there to witness
my first hour set down yeah I did a full
[ __ ] hour and I don't remember
anything that I said cuz it was such a
last-minute show I didn't I didn't get
the prep for it very well and so the
surprise he was like oh surprise we
booked you for an hour no I
it wasn't confirmed that I was gonna do
the show and it didn't seem like he was
gonna get booked so I didn't prep for it
oh it sounds like ah [ __ ] it it's not
gonna happen so and then when it got
booked booked there was like two weeks
out and I was busy doing other things
but I didn't really get to prepare but
the good thing is because I've done
stand-up for so long I still had a lot
of old sets in my head yeah and so I had
a tweak it to make it funny I mean some
of the stuff didn't do as well but I
mean Bart Joe said I killed it I don't
know if they're being nice but I
remember one pretty well I think people
were laughing I mean I did an hour and
then people were cracking up so
hopefully that means I did well yeah but
who knows like you know comedy - it's
one of those things that I felt like
after a while I started to die out for
me um not because I don't like stand-up
comedy anymore it was because I just was
tapped out like it didn't bring the same
joy oh because all I ever wanted to do
was be a stand-up comic originally
that's it yeah and then um after a while
it was just like ah there's other ways
to make people laugh and that's when
YouTube popped up you know YouTube was
away I was like oh I could make people
laugh doing sketches and writing and
there's other ways to express my humor
and get people to feel that same way
through a different Avenue and that was
through writing sketches you know doing
these comedy vlogs so you know
quote-unquote vlogs and doing that type
of [ __ ] so you've you've changed a lot
that's I changed quite it happens and
people people don't understand like
people Oh howdy how do you have your
life figured out I don't have my [ __ ]
I don't think anyone does nobody does it
and that's what happens a lot of people
they look at somebody else and they say
well how do I get to be that person
because they have everything figured out
they don't nobody [ __ ] has [ __ ]
figured out yeah I don't I don't know
what I'm doing at all out of our group
out of the main people I'm probably the
one that has is the most lost
no you're telling me I feel like I have
like zero I mean I have a loose
direction but I'm just I don't even know
how my life is right now I don't even
know how I'm living you know it's and
that's how life's supposed to be though
yeah I guess the advice that I would
give certain people that that I think
that I have everything figured out I
always tell them you know your there's
gonna be moments in your life where you
feel like everything is going right you
know your path you know your lane but
after year - you're three or four or
five you're gonna say whoa
I want more than this yeah and I want to
do something else and that that thought
scares them because they go well oh [ __ ]
now either one they feel like they're a
loser they feel like they're they're
just wasting their time or or whatever
it is but what they're forgetting is
that because everybody is so good at
going on social media and saying I have
everything figured out you'll pursue
your dreams find that goal tackle it and
then everything is [ __ ] good you guys
you [ __ ] six pack ten bullshitting
[ __ ] dude you don't have [ __ ]
figured out all you do is you go on your
[ __ ] Instagram you write a post about
how everything is great but you you kind
of mislead these people who are lost and
my thing is my brand is always [ __ ] I
say you know what I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm doing all I know is that when I
find something that I enjoy yeah in that
moment I'm going to try to master it to
the best of my ability if it doesn't
work out I had to figure out when I
should bail out or try something else
yeah and I think um as you're exploring
these different paths like you get to
know more about yourself whether you're
someone who works better under like an
organized type of position or if you're
an entrepreneur and you just want to
blaze a path yeah like it's it's very
interesting because yeah like when
you're talking about how you know after
your two year three you wanna you want
more right like you've achieved your
going you want more right and I feel
like when you have that feeling and when
you have that thought it's kind of like
I see it the way I see it is that you
now become an entrepreneur like you
you've become someone that wants to grow
more and not necessarily like under
somebody but like you just want to grow
and do more thing
yeah yeah and then I think I think for
me it's like I I feel like I'm more in
the middle but I'm also I think I lean
more towards someone who just likes to
follow and I don't think for you you
should think about it as you're somebody
who likes to follow a lot of the times
when you guys hear these self-help
podcasts and people give you advice
about [ __ ] then you think to yourself
like okay well I'm [ __ ] up because
I'm not an entrepreneur that's not most
people in this world most people aren't
entrepreneurs yeah like it's it's it's
difficult it's difficult for me and
people consider my Smee an entrepreneur
and I really don't see myself like that
I guess I am because I do own businesses
yeah you do but it's you don't have to
look down on yourself because that's not
your path oh yeah I I don't I don't
because like I think for me it's like
I'm just testing out these different
paths yeah and I'm just figuring out
what works best for me and like what I
prefer and what I like and I like
structure yeah and I like it if you were
to give me a list of things that you
need me to do and I'll do it yeah and if
you were to be like hey um I just need
some of these things kind of done you
just figure out what needs to get done
to me I'm just like I don't [ __ ] know
like I get so lost and so to me like I
know personally from like just
experience and practice that I don't
function that way yeah yeah and and and
that's like what I say - it's you know
you understand where your skills lying
and also you're a very important part of
a of a constantly moving machine yeah
yeah and without you this machine
wouldn't work there is like the top
person who thinks about these ideas but
we do need people to execute that house
very [ __ ] well and there's a lot of
knees yeah and there's a lot of
variability within that job right so for
example
nothing is ever like clear-cut right so
let's see if you're a producer and I say
hey I need this this and this you can't
come back and say oh we don't have it
you figure out and you give me options
yeah there's ways for you to have that
entrepreneur entrepreneur tenacity
within the job as you're doing your
tasks yeah yep and and and that's like
the thing that people have to realize -
like you just just don't look at what
we're doing and saying that oh I'm not
enough because I can't do what they do
or and what you'll find out too is it
let's say you want you really do want to
be an entrepreneur and you feel like
you're better at taking direction
instead of creating your own path
we'll find that of that group or that
company that you want to be with it
aligns with your goals yeah cuz there's
also a lot of free time where you
develop things outside of a career yeah
I'm saying so people kind of base their
whole identity off the job that they
have and and you know I I honestly feel
like a majority of myself and who I am
as a human being works outside of the
work that I'm doing yeah this job and
this career does make me happy like I
get to connect and you know people get
to hear these insights but outside of me
being on this microphone or me going up
on stage doing stand-up I have my own
personal life my own goals outside of
that and I look forward to right mm-hmm
oh but before we continue oh we do have
a sponsorship people that's right first
of all first of all let me just say this
before we go on here and start doing
this real quick with this amazing
company uh-huh that [ __ ] with genius
brain okay uh thank you for those people
who are listening and watching this [ __ ]
because without you guys companies like
audible what it [ __ ] with us so Effie
you know what I'm saying so let me just
go ahead and read off this piece of
paper real quick just to give you guys a
taste of what audibles about good
listening make you a better parent a
better leader even a better lover that
it doesn't say that they should add that
on the list they should but check it out
with audible you get access to an
unbeatable selection of audio books
including bestsellers motivation
mysteries thrillers memoirs and more
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet people with
audible originals the selection has
gotten even more custom with content
made for members now check it out the
book that I've been listening to on
audible is actually save the cat if you
guys don't always save the cat is if
you're somebody out there that wants to
be a screenwriter and specifically sell
very I say like Hollywood sellable new
movies or even if you're going the indie
route I really appreciate save the cat
I've probably so I read it once and I've
been listening to the audiobook as I
Drive just because it refreshes me when
I write these scripts right so when I
write these scripts there's there's when
you start off and you don't know
structure Blake Snyder's save the
is a great way to start check that [ __ ]
out and you can get an on audible.com my
friends so audible members can choose
three titles every month one audiobook
and two audible originals that you can't
hear anywhere else
audible members also get access to
exclusive audio fitness programs because
we all know a 6-pack is important mm-hmm
and if you don't want a 6-pack well
guess what living a fit life is great as
well dude live long so you can listen to
genius brain and listen to your audible
books dude okay so you'll so remember
you can listen on any device anytime
anywhere at home at the gym or on your
commute or just on the go you'll also
enjoy easy audio book exchanges rollover
credits and an audiobook library you can
keep forever even if you cancel sudden
so just cuz you cancel your membership
remember all the books that you do have
you can go back and listen to anyways it
is pretty awesome so remember audible
the most inspiring minds the most
compelling stories is what they have the
best place to list it get started with a
30 day trial when you go to audible.com
slash GB or text GB 2 500 500 and listen
for a change remember that's audible.com
slash GB or text 500 500 and listen for
a change get started on that 30 day
trial
son get on that [ __ ] and let me know how
you guys like you man like I really do
[ __ ] with audible.com like I'm not
saying I just use it just because it's a
sponsorship all right
audible is the [ __ ] all right now back
to a bad bad that we talked about I
don't know 100 whether you're an
entrepreneur or a worker but I mean like
it all blends in together and it just
depends on what like how you work and
how you function did you did you did you
ever want to try to be an entrepreneur
um I never really set any goals to be um
I think I started thinking more about it
when I when I first started out with JK
and just seeing them do their own
and do their own things under their own
brand I'm like wow
yeah she's firing isn't it it is
inspiring and it's very motivational
because when you're surrounded by
something like that you're like oh you
start believing that you can actually
achieve those things even though when
even though like you never thought you
could yeah it's like things started to
become more possible so like when you
guys had sip and you guys started out
like it was basically a concept and then
like I don't know like how much time has
passed but it felt so quick that you
guys already had a physical store and I
was like what the hell and to me it was
just kind of eye-opening cuz I'm like
man literally if you have an idea and if
you work towards making that come true
it will come true and it's like I mean
it's such a simple thought but it
I just never hit so hard for me until
that moment where I was like wow dude
like I must be a real lazy ass for not
wanting to do things like I'm thinking
about all these things but I don't do
any effort or put any effort into making
that happen and then when I saw them
like okay I should work hard but you
know if you if you think about it in
that case like for example with the
matcha spot that we have right sip that
happens because the team is amazing so
it's not because Jo and I sat around and
we said hey let's do a matcha shop cool
we're gonna get it done by ourselves so
we have obviously the main people so Jo
and I are more of a the marketing team
slash investors and then we have the
people who are really the heart of the
business which is dan jeremy Jun yeah I
mean yeah that there are a great team
but I also feel like if you guys didn't
push to find a great team or to trust in
a great team it would have never
happened yeah I mean it's it's it's
definitely a team effort and that took
me a while because I started to realize
too as I was you know opening a lot of
these businesses and you know I failed a
couple times isn't that I the concept
can be great but I also started to learn
that I should start investing into
people like the right people so a lot of
people talk a big game dude and you know
about the drama that I had with one of
my businesses dude [ __ ] that guy no you
know I'm pretty you know like no no no
hate or animosity towards him he's just
a [ __ ] dumbass and
like the dude it's that's what I [ __ ]
up on like I I invested in two more of
his skills that he portrayed as somebody
who knew what he was doing with food
rather than his business taxes tactics
and who he was as a person so like in in
his case the guy hasn't you know it's
kind of dumb when I really think about
it and I think like I against my own
instincts I said you know what this is a
friend of mine I'm gonna believe in him
but there's a reason why somebody would
fail to business before they start a
third one with me and the way he would
phrase it made it sound like he met the
wrong people and for me I was thinking
okay you know what I'm the right person
so with his skillset at me I could blow
this place up and the place did really
really really well yeah but the problem
with having a business that you just it
doesn't matter if it does well or not if
you go into work and you walk in every
day and you say you know what I hate the
people here I don't like being here no
matter how successful that business is
now in the future it's going to fail yep
because walking in and disliking what
you're doing is going to be a forever
struggle and that is something that just
doesn't go away mm-hmm and will just
kill you slowly on the inside and then
your business will become worse it's a
reflection of you yeah you know and
that's what we always want with all
these businesses that we do own we want
it to be a reflection of ourselves you
know specifically when it comes to like
sip or you know shrimp daddy or
everything now it's like customer
service is the biggest thing yeah I
think for me like when I walk into a
place like there are stuff that we could
arguably probably make it home but we
come into an establishment because we
want people to say I had a great
experience yeah you know so when you
guys come to sip and you guys check it
out if you guys have a bad experience
remember don't be quiet about that [ __ ]
like come up talk to an employee and say
hey like I felt like you guys were Pablo
or something else and we'll constantly
work on that type of stuff I just don't
like like that Yelp culture right now
where people are so [ __ ] brave and
they talk a lot of [ __ ] on Yelp but all
you had to do was talk to us when we're
at the business yeah and then we would
have helped you out it's not a problem
people are just weird like they just
want that attention it's just or maybe
or do they feel like they're the
whistleblowers I don't know so Yelp Yelp
has a thing right so there's actually I
read this book and
it had a lot to deal with like marketing
a [ __ ] I forgot what the exact
terminology is but people have this
thing of wanting to be the who's who in
the group meaning that I know something
that you don't know so that's why a lot
of these restaurants do have secret
menus the reason why you have secret
menus I mean it doesn't make sense if
it's an item that does really well why
not just put it on the menu
you know why is because it actually
creates like this marketing fervor for
something yeah so people though oh well
you know if you go to let's say what's
the what's a diner that you had oh you
know if you go to diner blue apples yeah
right if you ask for the pie and say you
want it flipped upside down in a but you
know what they'll do with that with the
apple pie is that they'll flip the apple
pie upside down put sugar and crust it
with it with the with the glaze on yeah
yeah I think oh I didn't know about that
so they like to be the person who knows
something about something that you don't
know I remember in and out was the
biggest cream oh dude the flying
dutchman all this other weird [ __ ] right
so and that's really a huge memory that
people have of in and out and people do
this a lot with restaurants and it's a
great idea and it's also it also creates
kind of a cool relationship with the
customer base and that's kind of what
Yelp does so Yelp is a way for people to
number one savings without
accountability because it's not their
restaurant hmm they could be if you do
do you up so I have a yelp review too
but I don't do it under my name mm-hmm
and I only give four or five stars and I
give that person to one star they must
have done something terrible
yeah but I don't think I've ever given a
one star because in my opinion if the
food is bad and the place is not good
eventually they will close down on its
own yeah so I don't have to go out of my
way to destroy a business another thing
I realized with some yelp reviews is
that people get really emotional in
there and it has nothing to do with the
food oh did you read some of these yelp
reviews are like okay so I woke up today
and I took a shower and my showerhead
wasn't working and I swear to god I told
my landlord to [ __ ] fix the water
nothing happened so I took the coldest
[ __ ] shower and the only thing that
was gonna help me with some hot mashed
potatoes so I walked into Denny's
[ __ ] does that got to do with Denny's
yeah and then when I asked for mashed
potatoes he came out five minutes late
and I was thinking what have hurt one
star I'm like hold on a second the [ __ ]
does your nan showering smelly ass has
to do with this [ __ ] business
you know like customer service I
understand if you were treated poorly or
if the food tasted bad like sure you can
rate it poorly but I don't even give bad
reviews for bad customer service as long
as the food is good that's just how I am
so if I go into a place a guy let's say
a French man walks up to me hello who
are you yeah you are a Chinese piece of
[ __ ] it is your burger and I eat the
burger and it's [ __ ] delicious I'm
like you can say whatever you want as
long as you gave me my goddamn burger
crunchy still gotta serve me that burger
[ __ ] and I just eat it and I'm happy
yeah yeah and I'm good like I won't I
probably won't give them a five-star but
I guarantee you I ain't gonna give them
a one because I hate the food and I was
happy I'm very simple to please though
like I'm not because my parents own the
business I understand what those reviews
do to a business yeah
you know and you know people aren't
gonna sit there and try to investigate
what's going on and a lot of the times
like like we were just talking about
this with one of my favorite restaurants
that's right around the corner yeah like
she was telling me that also let me tell
you this story hmm
there was a time where I walked in and
she told me that there was a very very
very rude customer and I'm talking about
this is this is the interaction that
they had so when I heard this to like
over my shoulder I just couldn't pick up
a majority of it yeah because I was
faced this way on the counter the other
way and then she kind of told me what
happened after but as she was being uh
she asked for the menu yeah and then she
was asking for something that was gluten
free of course LA everybody has to be
gluten free she asked for this gluten
free dish she goes cool
I go we don't really have like any
gluten free you know bread or whatever
Oh what I can do is I could put the
burger that you would like and put it on
a bed of frisée yeah and she goes she
goes how she respond to where she says
well that's not a burger a lettuce wrap
then is it hotdogs she goes I never said
it was a lettuce wrap I said I could put
it on a bed of frisée she goes don't
tell me what I said I did and I didn't
say
and I'm like yo dude she's like you know
just going off on her yeah she comes
back gives her food and then she just
super disrespectful at rudest [ __ ]
just storms the [ __ ] on out and clear
that person's gonna give Oh bad one-star
but if you hear that one-star review and
what it says it's like well this person
was the the the owner who's being super
disrespectful to me
didn't did it said that they had a non
gluten-free items and they clearly
didn't she was being snippy with me but
I was there and I witnessed it yeah and
that's not what happened yeah this is
this is the type of stuff that people
have to be mindful of like you don't
know what goes on with these like Yelp
reviews and these restaurants because
sometimes people are just [ __ ]
[ __ ] right and and I'm with you like
I think I'm pretty easy to please if the
service is whatever yeah like I mean as
long as the food is good like I'm happy
right and I think that just for me for
my reasoning of feeling that way is that
I also worked at a restaurant too and
I've dealt with so many different
customers and it's just like some of
them are just really rude and just
straight up rude and that's why you get
a rude response it's not the workers
that are being rude to you you're being
rude to them first yeah yeah and it's so
strange like yeah one of my friends I
she she I got super upset her because
the way she used to treat like waiters
and waitresses oh my god um for example
we were waiting outside to go eat this
is a Sacramento friend and you know
she's like one of my closest friends but
I got super [ __ ] mad at her because
she was upset at the staff because we
couldn't get seated in the time that we
wanted to get seated when the place was
packed yeah somebody was [ __ ] we were
outside it was so [ __ ] packed and she
was giving this lady so much attitude
like yo I understand if the person is
just waiting around and not doing
anything but do you not see like this
the front desk person trying like
they're sweating their ass off trying to
make sure that everybody can get a seat
yeah it's not like she's mistreating you
on purpose like you know we're not
getting a seat because she's not trying
yeah it's just that it was a huge influx
of people and then I remember like I
kind of like lightweight lectured and
she just sat there super quiet and as I
told her like yo you can't I can't go
out to eat with you that's how you
treats like staff and service because
you know if you were on the other end
you would [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] yeah
and yeah and I'm there so at the
restaurant
working at it there especially on
holidays it would get super packed right
super busy there's gonna be a lot of
walk-ins right and so typically if
there's like a party of four they would
like to sit at the boots right instead
of like a regular table and um our boss
would tell us that you know we we don't
we don't see like party of five on there
I mean like sure like you can probably
squeeze people like five people in it's
like but typically we we don't usually
do that right and so the hostess was
keeping in mind of that and so she was
like trying to seat this party of four
but then this party of five has was
there before the party of four and so
then the boss actually went in front of
the host is a big party of five here
follow me and she takes him to the booth
and then the host is like what the
hell's like you told me not to seat five
people there and then she was like oh
it's okay it's okay and I was like so so
it's not it sucks because I've seen very
poor management and the way that
customers see it and um like how the
hostess is being treated or the waiters
are being treated from management it's
kind of like you can't help but get the
bad service because there's no direct
communication like there's no clear
communication of like what is the
protocol because this hostess told me
that I can't be seated at a booth but
then now you're telling me I can yeah
it's hard there's a lot of things that
kind of you know and that's not really
the customers knowledge to understand
that and so like I get that part it's
kind of like yeah well it's I'm just a
customer I'm not here to fix your
personal communication issues like I'm
just getting that the bad end of the
service so it makes the restaurant look
bad
oh yeah and as an owner of a business
too we have to look at it as like okay
what can I do better then what am i
[ __ ] up on because there's a lot of
stuff that we [ __ ] up on to like you
said really like one of the biggest
issues that I had was hiring the right
people and I mind you like for me that
wasn't that wasn't really my job but at
a certain point I to step in and say
like okay well who are you really hiring
and you know with the business that you
know I'm going to let go babe we just
hired people who they thought were their
friends you know and it was so stupid
I'm like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about and and they just didn't
understand that like it's a
business mm-hmm you know and they didn't
think about structure and they kind of
like the way they would treat employees
and like give them knowledge would be
like okay well I expect them to know
everything it's like well how do you
expect them not you you had explained it
to them like they're your employees yeah
you know and so you know there's there's
a lot of issues that a lot of people who
think that they can be business owners
they don't understand that you're a
leader but you have to guide these
people on a regular basis and they have
to be able to trust that you know what
you're doing because if you don't know
what you're doing the whole system
breaks down oh ho yeah right yeah like
being under that management it just
drove me nuts and so I just literally
told him like hey I can't work here
because this year is a very important
year for me and it was just basically my
last year of college and like they were
just like no no no don't leave us like
we need you and I was like it's like I
don't know like I don't like I don't
think I can keep coming back right
because it just got so hectic and there
was like I was just so frustrating
working there every weekend and so then
um my boss was telling me cuz like so I
was a cashier for the longest time and
um she liked me as cashier because I was
fast and I was accurate with the money
like handling the money and giving the
checks out and everything and what was
annoying to me was how the pace system
was it's like look I don't like I don't
I wouldn't say that I'm a person that
feels entitled to how much I get paid
yeah but it's like but if you're hiring
someone to do their job like they should
do it correctly and so it was always a
cashier and then there's a hostess and
then there's waiters right and so the
hostess will be obviously seating people
right but then if customers have
questions
the hostess should be able to answer
them yeah so we had this hostess that
just only sat people but never answered
questions and she would always direct
them to me when I'm like already busy
with doing other things and the thing is
that the hostess gets tipped more than I
do
why from the Horsham but that's the
hierarchy that's why it was so
frustrating because I was like when does
a hostess ever get tip more than the
actual waiters and waitresses well no no
no no no no as a cashier attrition I got
tipped like Oh hostess got took more
than a cashier sure which makes which
makes sense right but it's like but if
part of your job is to be able to answer
customers questions like
I'm not here to babysit you and to
enable that bad behavior of you don't
know where you're talking about was she
like related to like via no she wasn't
she wasn't she just like I guess I get
some dick behind those doors
yeah only she kept referring them to me
and I was like what the [ __ ] like I'm
not I can't be doing your job to like if
customers come up to me and ask me
questions sure that's fine but if you're
gonna bring customers over to me because
you can't answer it I'm like that's
[ __ ] and so did you ever talk to
management about I did I did so like
that was one of the reasons why I didn't
want to come back was because that was
so frustrating and I was like telling
her I was like she needs to know because
if if she doesn't know then like I'm not
gonna be working here anymore because
it's way too hectic and I'm not I don't
get paid enough to do this essentially
right and so um she she was just things
like okay how about if you just come
once once in the weekend cuz I think I
was working on Friday Saturday Sunday
and she only wanted me to work on
Saturdays and also okay sure I can do
that right I was like but like I was
still kind of hesitant on it right and
then she was like I'll make you dope
okey every weekend it was like okay
missus oh it was food those food that I
was craving it was free [ __ ] food
David okay oh he was a Korean person huh
yeah look monkey in there [ __ ] mrs.
Kim yeah mrs. Kim if you work on a
Saturday only yeah I make you dog bokya
to make you smile yeah yeah so like she
kind of right away don't looking like
dammit that was the only thing that got
me it's weird because um like working
for Korean people and you know being a
Korean guy myself
yeah a lot of the times things that got
mixed up with in Korean businesses was
the the business and friendship part so
they try to create like a family
environment sort of you know but at the
same time like that because when family
and business mixes in they it kind of
goes worse than it does better right so
what I mean by that is let's say like
they [ __ ] up on the paycheck or
something right they're like okay well
I'll just fix it next week can you wait
it's like on an irregular basis like no
I need that money you need to fix it now
and there's no question about it but for
them they'll be like but I made you [ __ ]
you last week oh I thought we'd a family
yeah
we pour me a find maker you thought
bookie you kind of wait for me that's
not cool you know and so that's what
happens like where it mixes up a lot and
I think I used to hate that [ __ ]
and the one [ __ ] business where I
started with Korean people same [ __ ]
problem and there were issues that I
didn't know cuz I'm not there for the
day-to-day and I just can't really
support and push a business that would
do that to employees yes so yeah that's
what we're gonna have to move on from
that but it's so weird dude like it's
such a weird case like me you know we
could say that we're family and family
time is family time you know after work
you guys you can bond and have drinks go
on to like these company trips and
picnics but when it's work time it's
work time baby yeah that's what it's
supposed to be like so like okay so let
me ask you this do you believe in
tipping I believe in tipping if the wage
does not support their lifestyle for
example mm-hmm in Japan in other
countries right right aside from the US
there isn't any tipping but their wages
a lot higher yes and so there's there's
there's there's two sides to this right
so let's say I owned a restaurant right
and I told them I told all the employees
by the way in my restaurant there's no
tipping mm-hmm there's absolutely no
tipping yeah cool thinking what's my
incentive well you get paid $18 an hour
yeah but here's the thing because you
get paid $18 an hour and there's
absolutely no tipping I expect the
highest amount of service and I expect
your [ __ ] undivided attention when you
work because now I'm expecting a higher
level of skill sets yeah right because
I'm not paying somebody 18:17 whenever
$16 an hour to work this part-time job
if you're gonna come in and just
whenever you're in a bad mood or I have
to cater to you a [ __ ] like that I
expect somebody to be at a skill set and
a level to be paid that type of wait
yeah and that's what happens in other
countries when we went to a restaurant
in Japan yeah everybody service was on
point they make a living wage like I
even heard that people if you work at a
fast food chain at other other countries
like I say like like Thailand or [ __ ]
Japan it's actually a living wage you
can live off of that and they get paid
way better and people in America they
hear that they go how come they get paid
like that well do you have their service
do you work as hard as them mm-hmm do
you like I'm talking about in Japan it's
so [ __ ] efficient yeah yeah I go can
I get number one or two they go
I yeah and I moved three steps away your
orders ready yeah whose order boy
Oh my order that's how efficient they
are so I do believe in tipping in a
place where the wage won't supplement
how they're going to live but if you
want a higher pay you have to work for
that type of pay right you know yeah and
I feel like it's a hit and miss with a
lot of service industry stuff they go
well I deserve a [ __ ] tip well I work
a regular job too and I don't get a tip
but I understand that you're not getting
paid correctly so the tip system does
work for you right yeah yeah because
there's one time where um so this was
when I became a waitress at that
restaurant and I was serving this table
and this guy that was sitting there he
was just saying oh this is amazing
service thank you right and then I was
like oh yeah no problem I mean this is
what I like to do for you right and so
later um I heard like I guess there's
two girls I was sitting with them and
they're like oh my god like why would
you like say something like that or
whatever right he was like well that was
her tip two letters to let her know that
she that she did a great job and I was
like no and I was so confused I'll so
perplexed because like I understand that
if my service is shitty or if anything
like however you feel you can tip
whatever amount right whether it be $1
$2 $10 right that's up to your own
discretion right yeah but then like just
to hear that well it's just like it's
highly offensive isn't the [ __ ] it took
me back because I was like oh [ __ ]
like I guess that's one way to tip
someone by saying that they did great
service even though you don't leave any
money because then it's just like well
tip is optional right yeah yeah so I was
I was just very confused by that cuz I
just honestly didn't know how I felt
about that because like sure I'm not a
hundred percent entitled to it right
because that's it's it's additional it's
optional yeah yeah so when he said I was
like wow I was like that's a interesting
way of seeing things yeah you know and
some people are just [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude yeah some people are just rude as
[ __ ] yeah it's hard on the surface
industry because like your your job is
to make sure that this person or your
customer walks away with the great
experience but in that you also have to
exercise a lot of
patience because just because you are a
great person doesn't mean that that
person is gonna treat you the same back
right and that's the [ __ ] hard part
dude like they're do when I was at the
Men's Wearhouse dude let me tell you
about this [ __ ] dude I used to work at
the Men's Wearhouse in tuxedo so my
manager that hired me on first of all
shout-out to Ken Ken actually gave me a
job and I think like at the time I
needed a job really bad and he hired me
until they say we're still friends like
I thought that's awesome I've seen his
kids grow up and everything is so like
you know I consider him like family
family yeah every time I go back to
Sacramento I visit him that's how much
that's how long how much we connected
over the past years but when I what used
to work there dude I use to run to some
of the most [ __ ] customers man let me
tell you about this there was this lady
that came in and so during during tuxedo
times like when the the most popular
time for tuxedos are a couple times out
the year other than that they're not
popular is wedding season right which
usually happens during the summer to
fall around there that's like when it's
pop and pop in and then during junior
prom and Senior Prom the most popular
times for people to come in other than
that the business is pretty dead
especially for a tuxedo specific
business and so during this time the
place was called Men's Wearhouse tux OMW
tux and they acquired a previous company
from it and it just became M W tux later
and that's when I was hired on so during
these busy times I had a deal with some
[ __ ] stupid as customers now mind you
me being somebody who is at the time
didn't know how to exercise too much
patience depending on who it was I had
to deal with some [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
people so there's a kid that came in for
a tuxedo I remember this kid and I
measured him up I'm a bigger dude so if
a bigger guy measures him maybe he feel
a little more comfortable so the guy was
the kid was so big I mean no no fall to
his own he was mom he didn't eat a lot
but he had like a past like a quadruple
x vest so when you get a a vest size
that big on a tuxedo that's past my
quadruple s or 3x you have it's a
backless vest meaning that you do have
the front part of the vest and the back
is just straps and it doesn't really
matter because you're gonna have it over
a jacket anyways so that's how it is I
explained it to him I was like hey are
you okay with the backless vest you're
kind of on the larger side so there's
nothing in store that can fit you and if
you go anywhere else you're not going to
be able to find one
custom-made yeah and he goes oh it's
cool it's great it's not a problem man
cool so I fit this kid up made him feel
comfortable and the kid looks sharp his
foot yeah so after the after his junior
or senior prom is over he comes up with
his mom now his mom by the way I
remember exactly what she looked like
they she came into the store with this
baby blue [ __ ] floral print [ __ ]
muumuu outfit like this one-piece silky
and disgusting his [ __ ]
Oh walking and looking like [ __ ]
Mexican Jabba the Hutt dude like she was
huge dude by the way I [ __ ] what
Mexican people bound or not [ __ ] with
that [ __ ] so she comes in mad attitude
dude she goes excuse me sir I just
wanted to talk to your management and
you know my manager wasn't there at the
time yeah and I was like okay like well
he's not here but let me help you out
cuz I was closing up shop she goes I
want a full refund from my son's tuxedo
oh okay well what happened and she goes
she goes nothing happened
the tuxedo fit fine but his vest came
without it back so I want a full refund
for the tuxedo oh my god and I remember
because I fitted him he was like okay
man let me let me let me talk to my
manager real quick I'll give him a call
to see what I what I should do but you
did say the tuxedo fit well and I did
explain to your son that he can't have a
back to his tuxedo because once he moves
past like quadruple or triple X it
doesn't have a back and he said he was
completely okay with it yeah and she
goes well I wasn't aware of that and
then his mind you as she's returning
this tuxedo there's other people looking
for their tuxedos for their prom yeah
right so he had his probably there's
other kids you know every every school
has a different and so like she's
causing a [ __ ] scene yelling at me
and this kid is embarrassed like he's
sitting there site pissed because she's
basically announcing to every person in
that store that my son is a fat [ __ ] and
he can't fit anything and I'm sitting
I'm like ma'am you need to like lower
your voice and relax and I'm looking at
this kid and he's embarrassed right I
felt terrible for this kid and I know it
called me he goes to well he goes well
he said he enjoyed the tuxedo will just
give a refund on the on the vest and
then we'll move on from oh cool I'll say
I can do that I was like hey this is
what we'll do the tuxedo he liked it he
enjoyed it and the kid was like mom the
tuxedos fine like he's upset oh yeah
she's I shut up like I'm talking to the
guy you know she's like super surly and
I was like okay
we'll give you a refund on the vest yeah
she does know I want a full refund on
the tuxedo and I'm like I can't do that
because he understood that he liked it
your [ __ ] sons clearly said he enjoyed
it and we explained it to him I can give
you a refund on the best which was like
what 20 or 30 bucks I'll do that for you
right now and then she just starts
screaming at me I'm talking about at the
top of her [ __ ] lungs and I got so
[ __ ] upset I was like I got a clown
on this [ __ ] she had this lazy eye
you know I'm talking about lazy as [ __ ]
I'm talking about one eye directly into
my eyes and the other one just passed
the [ __ ] out to the side and so I looked
at it and I was like man I was like
unless you looked me directly my eyes I
cannot speak to you anymore she's like
excuse me I was like look me dead in my
eyes or I can't talk to you cuz that's
super disrespectful she goes I am
looking at you and I was like not from
what I can tell my clowning on there
dude and I got so upset I was like man
you know you're embarrassing your son
right now right you're basically telling
him that he was so large he can't fit a
vest and you're embarrassing your son
mind your [ __ ] manners like I'm
talking to my business she's like I'm
gonna call corporate blah blah blah
screaming and the kid is just like
hiding his face and she stands out I had
to deal with this type of [ __ ] all the
time
and then you she did call corporate I
told him a situation I was like she was
screaming at me yelling at me asking for
a full refund on a tuxedo yeah and I was
told that I should just give them a full
refund on the vest yeah and that the
tuxedo is fine and the kid was okay with
it
yeah they did they didn't reprimand me
and that's it yeah oh my god did I clown
on that [ __ ] dude she was huge people
oh that just infuriates me because yeah
I did encounter a few people like that
at the recipe I'll tell you this man I
was fat dude so when a fat person looks
at another fat person it goes goddamn
that's how fat she was she was huge she
was so fat her feet look like they would
explode like her
horseshoes had a [ __ ] nice lean to it
it was bad dude like have you ever
microwaved a [ __ ] ass more before and
you see that marshmallow soup off to the
side that's what her feet look like in
those goddamn sandals [ __ ] that [ __ ]
Wow
yeah I mean I'm assuming you never saw
them have you ever heard a [ __ ]
flip-flop scream no [ __ ]
that footed [ __ ] oh I just imagine the
the flip-flops be like extra flat yo I
don't know what she was sitting on she
was she was walking on a wing and a
prayer dude that [ __ ] waddle
she had a cane too by the way Oh because
she was huge she was like born a pound
yeah yo shout-out to that kid no for at
least like you know backing me up cuz he
was like yo he was like I'm good with
the tuxedo fit fine she's like no we
didn't get a back I was like I can't
help the fact that your son can't fit in
something past three or four X's once
you past three or four X's I have to
[ __ ] find a curtain and make
something out of it I can't help you did
you did you tell her that it had to be
custom-made if she wanted her back no
why I told it like you had to go buy a
vest which I buy but it has to be
custom-made yeah yeah it was [ __ ]
huge he was huge very sweet kid though
yeah customer service is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude do you know what I just realized
there was questions that I was supposed
to ask you whether we'd even get to it
oh really
it's an hour in ten [ __ ] minutes in
maybe maybe next time I know before this
podcast ends I need you to sing me one
R&B song that you like one R&B song
R&B rhythm and blues orangey rhythm in
gangster baby I don't know I can't think
of one on top on the top of my head
except for a like I believe I can you
don't sing that song Julia you know who
the [ __ ] things that it's are Kelly I
know but that's the only songs popping
into my head right now
oh wait this song Hey
if you're talking about RnB my mind
automatically goes into the I believe I
can fly song all right I'm sorry I used
to think that I could not go on and life
was nothing but an oh I don't know song
but now you know what [ __ ] that song you
know we're not singing that song next
another R&B song um oh my god what would
it what is it a ghostwriter
[Music]
Ghost Rider yeah I think it's called
Ghost Rider or something oh wait not bad
arm beat I'm sorry I don't know I don't
know a single arm oh dude like I can't
think of anything really
no Boyz II Men song I think I came a
little after boys tonight I will sing
this God not a single boy still nice
sorry
Jodeci I've heard about Brian McKnight I
just don't remember much of a song Casey
and Jo Jo for some one thing the first
though that's also something I played on
the piano it gave me some poser
mm-hmm I know that was a great song I
promise to never fall in love with a
stranger you're all I'm thinking of I
praise the Lord above then I finally
found you God
do better next time I'm terrible anyways
guys thank you for listening this
episode of genius brain podcast remember
we are an interactive space leave
comments below this podcast is just us
talking [ __ ] and having conversation man
a lot of podcasts have very like unique
guests that have this unique perspective
about their jobs and their careers we're
not doing that we're just having
conversation and having fun and we're
allowing you guys to be a part of this
conversation so leave comments below if
you're watching this on youtube remember
we're on Spotify stitcher cashbox iTunes
podcasts everything in on all those
audio platforms so just make sure that
you guys leave those five stars on those
comments below once again shout out to
audible.com for all your audiobook
listening needs we're talking about
audible.com slash g/b get all that [ __ ]
or text gb2 500 500 right that's five
zero zero five zero zero they say text
SMS code two five zero zero five zero
zero GP aren't you guys where can they
find you Julia
oh you can find me on my youtube channel
called X blue apples same thing with my
Instagram its X and then the color blue
and an apple and then there's a Z at the
end yeah you made a [ __ ] complicated
eyeshadow I did but you know what I'm
gonna stick with it man like I know a
lot of people give me a lot of flack for
that like dude this is a dumbass
screening that you had in high school
and I was like well you know what I'm
gonna stick to it I'm not gonna change
it to my real name that's right stupid
yeah X blue apples all the way thank you
I don't get you on this day